hi my name is Dustin Campbell I am a
software engineer on various c-sharp
things a c-sharp language team c-sharp
tooling cross-platform experiences all
sorts of stuff and you are
I am Masterson I am a p.m. on the C
sharp F sharp and VB team and I'm
involved with the evolution of c-sharp
it's a language so those are the things
we're here to talk to you about once
again this year we are happy to report
that c-sharp has a future and we'll try
to put some detail on that
so this year because I'm a p.m. they
actually said why can you please not go
near the keyboard this year so actually
Dustin will be doing all this I actually
insisted as an engineer I will not have
a program manager typing for me yeah I
tried doing a pull request once and that
sort of kind of that kind of did it for
me it wasn't in the markdown so we
didn't write so let's see there's
probably a clicker up here right here is
it okay it's got two two buttons it's
the green ones the one you want I could
probably do okay so every year Stack
Overflow or friends there they do a
developer survey they ask people what do
you use what do you like in the
technology realm that is but so I wanted
to give an update on that what it looks
like this year and once again this year
we're happy to see that C sharp is
pretty high on their list of the top ten
of most popular technologies as in most
used
okay so C sharp is pretty high up there
there are a few above us there probably
remain a few above us usually argue one
of them is not necessarily programming
language but
and and some of them are languages you
use together with other lists and so on
but no excuses it's good to be number
four that's really good
one thing that I really like to see
that's sharp there is that there's also
a list of most loved technologies that
the technologies that people use that
they would like to continue to use okay
so and c-sharp is on there too so just
being on both of those lists is kind of
an honor for us there's three languages
that are by the way if you if you
contrast this c-sharp its typescript and
it's Python so that's pretty good for us
all three are well supported initial
studio for instance that's that's a good
thing so we kind of want to keep it that
way it keeps me sharp very highly used
but also very highly loved so so
hopefully the things you see today that
we're thinking about we already put out
very recently in c-sharp seven oh and
then we're thinking about for coming
versions of C sure they will reinforce
the love that's it's certainly it's
certainly sent to you with love so
hopefully I'm feeling loved in this room
right now yeah right yeah I wasn't
getting that but now I am yeah yes so we
we also want to touch a little bit on
sort of the the landscape the context
that C sharp is in we have three
Johnette programming languages that we
as Microsoft are heavily engaged and
there are this out there but these are
sort of the ones that we really push
from our team side and I want to touch
just a little on the the state of the
world there and how we think about those
languages going forward c-sharp
obviously used by millions of people
today and in a very very wide range of
different domains we're actually
somewhat flabbergasted to see the range
of domains of people use C sharp for and
so it's a language that needs to satisfy
many different styles of programming
many different constraints that you have
in your domain and accordingly our our
strategy for C shared really is to keep
aggressively evolving it so that it will
be a satisfying experience it
English that you would want to pick up
for your next project we want to keep it
relevant s not just something that well
we started there so I guess we've got to
stay there but a language that people
would pick up in this vast array of
domains again of game development low
level development enterprise lots of
mobile development and so on like so
many different scenarios that it's
strong in all of them so we really have
a duty here to keep F to keep your CTR
for rather relevant in all of those
visual basic used by hundreds of
thousands of people it's still very very
popular language it's declining a little
bit but not precipitously and the set of
VB developers is sort of by and large
they're very many exceptions from buying
lights for more homogeneous then then
instead of c-sharp develops in terms of
the domains that they address we're
talking a lot of line of business
applications a lot of applications built
by people who aren't primarily in
computer scientists or professional
developers but building things for the
business starting out with VB itself
tart and and stuff like that and so for
VB it's important for us not just to
throw everything everything in the
kitchen sink in there but to focus on
the features that a a relevant for those
domains B are necessary in order for VB
to be fully first-class language when
the framework evolves for instance like
the language features such as tuples
that need to instruct with the framework
and also and language that is
approachable for a lot of people it's
many people's first language and for
many people it's the only language they
ever pick up like the share of people
who come to dotnet as their first
development experience that use VB is
much higher than the VB share in general
so it's important for us to keep in mind
and finally f-sharp is really a
juggernaut and is growing very very
healthily in terms of usage and it's
it's actually being used again in a lot
of different scenarios it is a real it's
a real general-purpose language but it's
seeing extra strong usage in more
analytical workloads data science that
kind of thing have
math into it and where you have
architectures that are sort of very
pipeline II and it and if I if I might
add I mean the community around F sharp
is extraordinarily vibrant what's per
capita it's amazing how many people just
are giving back to the community they're
so F charm is really driven by the
community to an extent that the other
two languages can only dream of and has
really actually helped us think about
but when we went open-source and doing
community and so on F sharp was totally
like a trailblazer there and they still
are lots and lots of the very cool
features you get in the F sharp tooling
and the language itself it's on there
actually contributed by the community
and our role with F sharp is to help
provide the infrastructure so that your
community is able to write all these
different contributions and also remove
any barriers there are two adoption such
as well the tooling isn't as good as for
c-sharp and VB well let's go and and do
the do the work to remove that barrier
and make the tooling great it's
interesting when when Kevin ransom from
the F Drive team whenever he comes to to
stand up he it's like what you do
yesterday well I I merged eight PRS you
were any code no no no I just merged
yeah it's all David merging at Festival
we're not kidding
it really is so F shot really great
there and we we're expecting lots of
great stuff from F sharp in the years to
come but we are going to talk about
c-sharp let's talk about the road ahead
for c-sharp we already just released
c-sharp 7 Oh as quickly as you can
please get into a position where you can
use it if they won't let you at work
like do it at home or whatever it's it's
just so much better like it's it's it's
a whole 1.0 better than c sharp 6 thank
you so yeah it's one we don't want to do
and it came out so recently we're
actually going to kind of recap some of
the some of the features in c-sharp 7
here as we do a demo along with the the
nice editor work that's there we're
going into the business of point
releases so we've said c-sharp 3.0 4.0
5.0 6.0 all the way up and we did that
for a reason that's because we
anticipated that when we will get to 7
we would start having point releases so
will actually start releasing smaller
upgrades to c-sharp and the first one is
actually we're starting in the preview
that was released here and built it
doesn't actually it only has one
language feature enhancer right but I
only think of this is the second point
release because there was c-sharp one
point to one of your goods yeah yeah
that's probably how we got into it so so
we think that there will be times where
we want we have some value we don't want
to sit on for whatever the period until
the next major release some stories that
we that need a little fleshing out so
and we want to feel free to just release
a point version of c-sharp sometimes
there are scenarios that we want to
align with in the framework for instance
that need a little language kind of
magic sprinkle on top and we want to
feel free to do that so we're starting
doing point releases starting with this
update three that you've got a preview
of today there's only one language
feature in the preview but we have more
of them working and yet more of them
coming and we're going to touch on that
again in the demo and yes so they're
gonna be plenty of demos of this then
we're thinking that's a c-sharp 72 and
please bear in mind that these are like
these are milestones and the set the
feature sets for the my intentions like
we just want tags to talk about our
intentions you can go and get help and
see us talk in terms of these releases
it's not a promise to you you can't sue
us Engineering schedules around these
features being there exactly in a
certain day but you just feel bad yeah
instead of just waffling about it all
the time we just say let's put some tags
on it and then and be clear about our
intentions and then as all plans change
our plans change too as we find out
something's too hard or doesn't actually
really make sense after all or whatever
that happens surprisingly often so
c-sharp 7/2 is where we want to focus
more in particularly in the framework
and some in the runtime on we sort of
want to push unsafe code out of c-sharp
in a way or to move more to the corner
having more low-level code that's safe
and efficient more interrupts with
native memory and and other things like
that so 7/2 is as the language release
that has some features that helps with
that it's not for most people but if
you're like a unity developer which a
lot of people are that's going to really
help you you're trying not to trigger
garbage collections well yeah there's
some stuff that is going to be cool
people who are building the lower layers
of ASP
Kestrel signal are all that stuff
they're gonna build a more robust more
efficient foundation for everyone else
to target and so we think it's worth it
even though there may be some language
features that aren't for everyone
right I mean typically unsafe is kind of
supposed to be covered escape hatch when
you need to go do these extra things and
now they're kind of becoming it's
becoming fundamentally important for
various scenarios right so it makes
sense for us to go and do managed ways
of doing those things yeah so we're not
going to show any on this today I'm just
telling you that's the plan that it's
coming and you can you can go to the
github site and see what's what's
rumbling there c-sharp 7-3 may or may
not happen at all in my head right now
that's where we sort of take the next
steps of the pattern matching are we
gonna talk about in a bit that we put
into c-sharp 7o and then at some point
there's going to be a major release we
call it c-sharp 8 it's just a little
joke we have and and that's where sort
of the major language features the next
major language features are gonna going
in we will show you some of those as
well because we have demos some of that
promise they won't crash yeah they won't
crash at all so why don't we flip over
to your lap yeah absolutely that's a
nice that looking some stuff yes all
right
hope everybody can see that so I'm gonna
type you go ahead what would you like me
to show okay so let's start out let's
start out simple let's get ourselves an
array of numbers
okay I'm let's say they're the powers of
two all right I which have undoubtedly
you all know by heart but a fertile Wiz
yeah up two fighter and probably an
embarrassing level but just just to make
a point here it would be easier if we
could sort of see that this is binary
right it's related to binary if we could
sort of see the bit patterns there so
that's a refactoring now yeah actually I
think in the preview right yeah I
believe so so this was actually
contributed by a community member you've
really wanted a way to easily convert
between bases and so yeah these are
decimal numbers let's go ahead and we
can convert them pretty easily to two
binary yeah cuz binary literals
inerrancy Sheriff yeah well isn't that
cute yeah there is super cute
which is why we added it yeah okay of
course yeah that's why we build features
as they're cute
if you're learning programming or you or
you or you actually have bid patterns
you want to write some of us know hex by
heart of course but it's actually nicer
to I'm getting old and I am a p.m. so I
like looking at the bid parents directly
of course they get it same to get kind
of long sure
answer the other thing you can do with
these literals is that and again that's
a refactoring here
let's stick in some well-placed
separators separate nipples separate
delightful please that's delightful and
if you're in if you're if you have a an
enormous hex number it'll say separate
words yeah we all have any big enough
that's why we did it because nibbles is
cute cool so but enough with this little
stuff let's let's call a method to tally
these numbers which means in today
today's talk that means let's count them
and let's also add them yeah I'm gonna
go ahead and use the refactoring to go
ahead and bring that so you can have a
generator and so the question is what
should we return in the count or the I
won't change this to values hold on
there we go that's better than okay
great yeah yep should we return the
count or should we return the sum right
that's always the question you're faced
when you have multiple results how
should you do this well now why don't we
just return both okay so we can return
yes and enemy like Zack that's so that's
a tuple type how many of you here
dislike tuples dislike well they just
like the error there so for those of you
that haven't done it yet
in the options there is a very important
option here under c-sharp yeah I know
it's crazy in here you could actually
you could search for it I just want to
show you where it is if you want to
actually direct yourself there at the
very top here there are a couple of
important options that are unchecked by
default these are suggesting using four
types and reference assemblies suggests
using four types in NuGet packages and
that's especially important when you get
started using tuples especially if
you're in a an existing project you
created net framework project cuz this
has hasn't actually shipped in the.net
framework yet Windows has not updated
with the dotnet framework with this
quite they're in in essence so what you
can do here is once you
that on and it downloads in the
background says okay I've now index a
large portion of NuGet packages that are
available are the most popular ones and
then I can press control dot here and I
can install system value tuple so I've
got the underlying type just fine yeah
so the gist here is tuples are built on
some underlying type it's not in the
existing frameworks will be in future
frameworks in the meantime just get it
and you'll get package for those
underlying tight yeah alright so that's
pretty cool well I'm gonna we don't want
to throw here we don't want to throw
let's actually at least do a dummy
implementation you can get the default
value there that's exact that's kind of
a little unfortunate it is I I
especially hate double parens for gather
double friends there sometimes writing
default of something it's like hey
that's annoying I just said it over here
on the other side of this assignment do
I have to say that type again and see
chap seven one you actually don't some
yes you can just delete the type there
and you can just have you just have
target type default expression so this
is a brand new feature as part of
c-sharp 7.1 it's okay to express your
your yeah oh oh but this is an error
actually it's one of the things I've
liked about our demos recently is that
we haven't had squiggles when we use new
language features this one has a new
language as a new language feature does
have an error the reason is because this
is a c-sharp 7.1 feature but you guys I
mean you might be working on mixed teams
you might have projects that are c-sharp
seven you don't want c-sharp seven one
features to sneak in there yet because
you're still maybe on somebody's using
Visual Studio 2017 somebody's using
Visual Studio 2015 that's our situation
so so c-sharp 7.1 is not activated
immediately but by doing this we were
able to recognize that in fact you try
to use a c-sharp seven point one feature
and I get yet again another light bulb
and that light bulb tells me that that
features not available but it offers me
fixes to upgrade the project to set the
Langan property on this project so I'll
go ahead and do that right here
if you grab preview bits today that
actually doesn't work and dotnet core
projects yet it will by the time we we
push this out to our TN this is part of
the Visual Studio 2017 update three
that's out there right now in preview
form
yeah so the thing with point releases
this we introduce a separation between
major and minor release
and you can you can set your preferences
to to the latest major or the latest
minor depending on how much on the edge
you want to be and by default Visual
Studio will come with it's set to latest
major yeah
okay actually let's do this Oh actually
make this a tuple here yeah so actually
you have to bow tie so you also have two
literals so you can write again just
some expressions comma separated
parenthesis kind of straightforward
there so we get into zeroes out you know
consume it yeah yeah let's go up here
and let's go ahead and oh I don't know
why it's are you whining about why did I
insist yeah okay well see use a less
using interpolation ring that's a thing
we do now a lot
everybody's doing in there yes can you
bring up the completion again oh sure
yes so what you see is a tuple has this
two bowl of two has a very informative
names inside item one and item two okay
so that's great it means I can get at
the first thing and the second name but
who can remember sometimes I said some
first sometimes I said count first we
can't remember which is the salmon which
it's again it's hard to remember you
know I'm pretty sure that when everybody
when people raise their hands about
disliking tuples they meant the old
system tuple type where you have I don't
want an item to right those are kind of
a drag so so these tuples would actually
be nice if you could if you could have
some names to indicate what you were
doing so let's do that
sure so we put names on there and we can
actually so so tuples can tuple elements
could optionally have names actually if
you go and most attractive variable for
that Google body there absolutely we can
so we can so we've got an expression
body right now this is an expression
body because I actually I'm just going
to give it a little interjection I'm
sure because as part of Visual Studio
2017 we're introducing more of a notion
of being able to define your own codes
code style in the product how you want
where you want squiggles to appear for
your style but also you know being able
to say these are the these are the ways
I want code to generate and I've
actually come in here and said that I
want to use expression bodies for
methods when possible and so when I
press the control dot and I brought up
the light bulb and and and generate that
generated me an expression body
right now I don't really want that but
I'm gonna go ahead I can fix that
there's a couple of ways
there's one that refractory I could just
come here and press control dot and say
I want to use a block or I could come
here and I could just introduce local
which will necessarily have to put a
body around yeah that's cool yeah so now
we can
so one thing you note is this a tubule
literal without any names converts just
fine to a tubal type with a name but we
can also put names directly in the
tubule literal yeah so we can call this
let's call them something else see see
to make a point and you see we're
actually
so even two tools have names but then
but they're not sort of strict about it
you can assign you can convert freely
between two balls with the same or
compatible types inside even if the
names are different they're just really
a guardrail and what we what you can use
them for oh yeah let's actually yeah
there's all sorts of ways you use one of
the things that actually totally
irritates me is when I want to use the
same name as the thing that I've been
passing around so I've got name it and
then say it again
or like R&R but you know maybe you know
okay yes there I want to give a good
name but when I've got the same name
right there it's not really it comes
it's gross I feel like defensive okay
come on come okay sorry I feel that
we've move I feel ashamed so let's deal
with it man I will deal with it as part
of c-sharp seven point one not in the
bits you have today because software
engineering is a real thing and we have
the same problems as everybody else and
we we forgot when the snap date was and
so we were ready to check in the date
afterwards but it'll be in the next one
okay and that is that we will infer
member names for tuples from from
variables or from names that are passed
in so variables or fields that are
passed to it you hover and so I can
hover and we can see that it actually
does have the name values it does have
the name R and those are inferred so
this is part of c-sharp 7.1 again we're
taking a feature and making it better
yeah
okay now I do want to consume I want to
see on the consumption side with these
names a good for us so you see the T
that item one is actually still legal is
this underlying names are still there
but this is a suggestion up there
there's like a little smudge yeah I mean
that's what that's what hunter was
calling with a smudge it's not yeah I
don't think it sounds like it's
marketing approved but yeah you can see
what this looks much it's trying to tell
us yeah yeah
so this mud is trying to tell us that we
should use the explicit we provided
tuple name there so because that's
coming out of the method as the return
type it says hey I should be able to use
some right here yeah and actually if you
if you pull the completion up again you
can see that we we hide the bad names
even though you can use them just show
the good ones they don't naughty name so
the tools have a very they have this
ability to communicate the purpose of
the returned values the same way that
you communicate the purpose of
parameters when you pass them in like
this kind of a symmetry there you'll
notice and in all the syntax we chose
for tuples they're kind of similar to
parameters just go in the other way
yeah we had this whole long debate and
we went back and forth and people went
back and forth about like should they be
you know uppercase tin Pascale case like
properties their fields cuz that's what
they are or should they be lower case
because they come back I've totally
settled on lower case yeah so yeah yeah
okay so so that's really good
what do we want to do next oh we should
implement tally what's that I think we
should implement tell oh yeah we have an
actual doesn't actually do anything no
it doesn't do anything oh good idea
okay cool it might be line for a p.m.
demo but that's as I'm yeah I kind of I
took my hand there so yeah can you ever
reach over those silly saying I guess
let's go ahead and fill let's do some
real work then all right I guess I use
this is what we do all day yeah loose
okay so we can actually go in so we have
that our that that returned to a ball we
use it as an accumulator right we can
update it every time around giving
creating a new tuple level with the with
the the some of the existing value from
it and the the count again
I mean and the account gets updated by
one you can't plus plus say you have two
plus one do it yeah I do
I prefer that you do okay but I think
you kind of gave something away there
that's okay so so so first of all let's
observe here so people might be
concerned
oh he's creating a new tuple is he
allocating is this bad for performance
and and it's not because that underlying
type that we talked about the tuples I
implemented with it's actually a struct
so unlike system that tuple that you may
have used to solve your multiple results
problem in the past
these are value types they are not
allocated they're just like chunks that
get copied on assignment all right just
chunks of memory so so no allocation was
harmed during this journey but actually
so what so what's funny is that actually
not only they they struct but they are
actually mutable structs that's true and
I may have accidentally shown that yeah
that's that's the thing you - so
actually that you can mutate them the
elements so instead of so maybe you can
do you could do this instead by by
incrementing yeah the s and and the C
with proper values so why are you doing
it in an assignment I don't know what is
it that's cuz that's what's on the demo
sheet you gave me no it was not
yeah so I could write it like this I
could totally I'm writing it out I'm
kind of put it up on the web I could
totally write this right maybe so if C++
in your code there you need a semicolon
you're sharper oh it's okay yeah you
could totally you could totally do this
with mutation because 2 plus mu double
case immutable structs it's actually
even worse people will go like Oh
mutable structs isn't that bad didn't
you tell us for like 10-15 years the
mutable starts a bit well they're bad
because of things that can happen when
you have function members that mutate
you have mutating function members on
there like methods or properties and you
call them on redolence trucks and you
actually they end up happening on a copy
and and and people don't realize they
have a buck and they don't mutate but we
do not have any mutating functions
because the elements are not properties
because they are feel
so we actually so tuples are actually
structs with mutable public fields
exactly what we told you never to do
yeah and and it was totally cool for us
but don't do it yeah we uh what were we
on that day what were we whatever we had
you know as in high demand but what we
had actually was insight it's like hey
we're not trying to build some thick
abstraction here tuples aren't important
it's not the tools that are important
it's some values inside like then we
just want a few variables and so we did
the simplest thing possible which is to
just offer up those variable mutable
fields and that it totally does the job
yeah
so so there let's see what are we going
to do next
do we want to actually one thing that's
interesting also about tuples is that
you know it kind of helps an existing
problem with async and c-sharp v that
you can't use out declare the variable
so now that I can return multiple values
yes I can I want to say in general as
he's typing
you know tuples compose really well with
other types that just types they
actually have the right value equality
that you can use them as keys in a
dictionary for instance if you want to
key on two things in your dictionary
just use a tuple type of the key and
that's all pretty slick but also just
composing with tasks in a
straightforward way and that's how you
get multiple results back from an async
method right now where you can't train
statues out parameters if that was how
you did it before they not allowed me I
got rid of most of the errors there's
yeah so you were well you made it a
thing you even change the name like just
suppose I but not enough that I'm
engineer right it's automatic yeah good
but also so now we're just waiting in
and getting the tubule bag out but of
course we're in the main method which is
not async however yeah c-sharp seven
again not in your bits today but coming
soon
[Applause]
again again remember that our intention
with c-sharp 1.1 is really just to kind
of you know add a couple of extra
features that really enhance existing
ones and so this is one that enhances
acing it's been missing for a couple of
releases to be honest seven one was like
hey we gotta learn how to do this point
release stuff yeah it's a really easy
once analytical main ass before I don't
have any connection to each other but a
sync main is great like it's it's funny
because I don't know that many people
actually write console apps that are
acing and ship them there's probably
some but it's not really a it's just I
sit I'm sitting down to learn a sink
well let me start out by well how do I
actually start out how do we get
something icing to start with us I'm
doing my first console app where I'm
trying to investigate a so now just the
yeah main methods can return tasks and
task event as well as well as void and
and int and when they do you're allowed
to make them async and there you go you
can await from the beginning that the
the runner knows how to not stop kill
the program until you've waited the task
that gets returned from the main method
feels like you want to you want type I'm
watching yeah yeah maybe a bit of a
developer in me so let's back out of the
async stuff again I think did we cover
everything there's a couple more things
there's a couple or more nuggets I mean
there's c-sharp seven we added the the
value tasks for example oh that's right
yeah yeah so you don't have to return
tasks anymore you can build your own and
the async state machine thingy and the
compiler will pick it up it's probably
like it's kind of hard to do right but
we build a few for you that for instance
value tasks there so that you can do
this with so that you can write
asynchronous code without having to
allocate yes value tasks is really like
a wrapping value type for this for the
reference type that tasks are so if you
have the kind of acing that where you
often where the result it's often
already available when you are waiting
then the value task will know never to
allocate a task so it's good for memory
intensive asynchronous stuff over
buffers and stuff like that and so one
of the one of the big things we did
there is is really in c-sharp seven
generalizing the notion of something
that's tasks like so that you can go
write your own task library if you're I
guess John skeet I don't know who else
would yeah just eat wood
and told Stephen Taub would actually
yeah he wrote GPL so it's good for the
rest of the world that they are there so
so now now something I'd like to show
here is often in any synchrony you know
you want to you want to do this you want
to pass this cancellation token around
and when I do that I you know I'm typing
in cancellation token see a cancellation
so at this point I've given up because
it's not actually in the system
threading tasks name spaces a different
age space but by now I've typed enough
that are kind of are fuzzy matching for
ad using that came in this release has
already figured out that oh yeah you
probably want the system threading
namespace and will correct the
identifiers for you and then also in the
preview bits for update three if I press
space here suggests for me a parameter
name which is exactly what I want
because I hate typing that as well yeah
it just looks at the type and comes up
with some good names there yeah you
always want these to be to be you know
optional because it's optional sometimes
you might want cancellation not always
the case but sometimes but of course
this is where the new default
expressions really that's much nicer
eight okay all right now we can back up
now we don't have any of those yeah so
for sure let's take the a thing stuff
away again all right undo because
otherwise things won't work the
fascinating process of making sure
visual Studios undo stack continues
working yeah that's one yeah and then as
you're demoing not going too far yeah
and they're not going too far what I was
watching carefully yeah so let's come
back to those tuples and this very in
particular the consumption experience
again up there in the main method okay
I'm tally you know right here we consume
right yeah yeah actually there yeah so
so I said we don't you don't actually
really care about the tuples they're
just sort of a carrier for the multiple
results that you're getting so it would
be nice if you never had to sort of talk
about the tuple or talk to it by dotting
into it or whatever and just make it
fade into the background and you can do
that with deconstruction which is
another new feature in c-sharp so there
you can say int s comma int see for
instance declaring two new local
variables and doing it in sort of a
tuple syntax on what is that the
left-hand side of the assignment they're
saying I want to take that result that
comes back whatever it is immediately
deconstruct it and put the elements of
it into these two new variables so that
down some now I can use s for the other
one it seems kind of silly that I named
C it's silly that C has a name yeah cuz
you're not using it no I'm not using
yeah you could do you could just discard
that okay that's so yeah you can use the
underscore now too if you are doing a
deconstruction you don't care about the
thing just discard it with this just in
C sharp seven does that's that's on the
box already yeah you can do though notes
go do this okay and actually you know we
know what's we know what's getting
assigned to us we can totally infer the
type of that s that's left there we have
this far in there and our in here and
when you're there where you have like
all bars or discards like seven of them
no you're never gonna return a seven
tool but you know you can just factor
the bar out you mean var at all all
right so you can do that bar everything
all right and so just put names and
discards in there that's kind of neat
that's that's a very concise expression
of what exactly you want to keep from
what comes back from a telling method
yeah deconstruction works not only on
tuples but it actually can work on your
own types there's a that's a pattern you
have to follow the deconstruct a method
did you have to add as an instance
method or an extension method oh you
want extension methods I can put it in
his types and and then your types can be
deconstructed like this as well okay so
so it's an open feature it's not just
very similar pattern base that we've
done before like we get a waiter methods
with with the link the link methods all
of it yeah yeah and as we saw with the
with the value task before like instead
of types being hard-coded into the
language there's the pattern that people
can follow and and hook into the new
language features yeah I'm not gonna
tell you exactly what it is here instead
let's go and go crazy with some can
imagine right yeah actually oh yeah
local functions yeah yeah there's one
thing we want to do first right which is
you know local functions that came early
so it's easier to forget yeah so yeah
yeah so so we want to actually before we
go extend the behavior here we want to
factor out an important piece of the
logic inside of this method
so that we can be use it in multiple
places so we write a little method that
takes that that abstracts over the
adding more to the sum and the count
that we have in scope here and we're
doing that with a local and local
function so we're just writing a method
declaration in the middle of the method
and then calling it I can move it
anywhere
right and yeah it doesn't even have to
be declared before it's called to
suggest a local we call them local
functions and they as you can see it has
just like a lambda it has the the local
enclosing local variables in scope so
this one for instance is mutating the R
that's outside of it so that's really
nice for helper helper functions is
really nice that you really don't want
to expose them even to your other
members as a private sometimes and also
that's a note that's annoying sometimes
you have to pass all these parameters
that is part of the local state if if
you want to mutate it that's hard and so
on this is just like you could it right
where you want to in scope of the things
you want to you want to edit so that's
so we got a local function there I'm
capturing the essence of adding so I've
got idea I want to I want you want to
talk about pattern matching so yeah I'm
so stoked about make this something
something that's got all sorts of stuff
go so make it like an object array
that's crazy it's silly I know yeah so
so let's say that instead of just an an
array of numbers we have like a nested
array of various things that might be
numbers and we still want to tell you
them so yeah we have to update our tally
method to take them but now we have this
problem of course that the V that we're
getting to is now no longer an int it's
an object so in Moulton c-sharp whether
you do this right yeah you'd maybe like
check if its own head in there yeah
check ups and cast it and asked it yeah
yeah but fortunately there's a smudge oh
this is much this is just kind of
generally what we're trying to do right
we want to make sure that as we've got
this great Rozlyn infrastructure in
there we can build code fixes and
diagnostic analyzers and do all these
great new tooling features as we build
the language we're looking for
opportunities to say to spot ways that
you could use new language features you
could write code you know in a newer
newer style maybe maybe maybe brief or
more concise that sort of thing and so
here it's it's suggesting to me to
use this feature pattern-matching yeah
well do it yeah
done yeah whoo okay what just happened
there is that the local declaration went
away and instead the is expression
changed a bit
instead of saying B is and I it says o B
is in it now says V is in I so what it
does essentially is as it's checking the
B's and end when it knows it is we might
as well grab it and give it a name like
here's the anti that's the value that
was in me that was an INT yeah okay so
that's what it mean yeah minds blown so
you all have that you either use is and
cast and you hate doing two casts or you
use so yes and you hate checking for
null yeah you know this just packs it
all into one you've got but I there is
something special right yeah you can do
two other things here there's a pattern
right so I could put other different
there are different kinds that's it so
it's important to note that in I in
itself here is a new thing in c-sharp
it's a pattern we don't have patterns in
c-sharp up until now but here they come
this this is a type pattern patterns are
things that can essentially test a value
for a certain property if you will and
also extract information from it as it's
doing so and they're known from
functional languages like F sharp has
lots of patterns we have a few there's a
tight pattern there there's a constant
pattern you can write null or an int int
literal or string literal thing all the
constant expressions you can check if
the thing is that is equal equal to that
definitely so constant patterns as well
so we're gonna we're probably goes we
got like all these objects we've taken
it and we've got all sorts of values up
there we should we're gonna have to do
like a big bunch of elsif yeah so first
I wanted to change it back oh sure yeah
yeah we could do this with else ifs and
a lot of is expressions but since we
were checking V all the time it's like
everything's about V here why don't we
just switch and be okay switching on an
object which was not something I could
switch on anything that wasn't like a
primitive or a string before but now you
can switch on whatever you want and your
cases can have patterns in them right
what you didn't know what we actually
didn't know was those cases that you had
all through C sharp one to six were
actually pattern
based switches on constant patterns we
just didn't know it at the time but I
tried it and it was just yeah yeah but
now that's what they are like yeah
constant patterns are just a special
case here of of course cases are on
patterns so you can take case and I if
the thing is an int give it the name I
and in the body of that case you can use
I just like we saw before with if
there's a bunch of others up there we
should yeah there's like an object array
at the end so we want to deal with the
object array uh-huh we can do that in
terms of itself right so we can call
recursively here we can call tally with
the object yes yes you call the method
again on that out of array you get
something out you add it to what we have
here
all right persons are going in it seems
the engineer in me says that's
inefficient that I should be checking
the length I shouldn't be calling off to
members if it turns out that there's
nothing in there yeah right we want
check when length is greater than zero
that's cool
[Applause]
yeah of course cases have conditions
right that boolean conditions and the
stuff you got they might not want to go
here now of course now we still have
those empty object databases we usually
check but oh my god we can use a discard
yeah because we don't actually care
about it we just want to say skip that
one all right
there's a there's also the case that
somebody might pass and null right we
use a default like we do need a handle
let's throw an exception if if the thing
that comes in can't possibly be
interpreted as a number let's throw an
exception
so one thing you notice here is that it
didn't used to be the case that switch
statements were order dependent but they
are now actually actually they always
were it never mattered yeah so there's
no breaking change here at all we could
always put this anywhere
yeah the default always is executed last
little swipe anywhere but you should put
it it you should put it last I want to
put right there it's like oh come on so
so it's like it's like with the
exception with catching exceptions right
you execute them in order the first one
that's that fits you grab and so this
sort of just when you see oh this is an
object array let's try this one then you
try the condition it didn't work you go
on to the next one and it gets called
there so now automatic in in switch
statements it's worth noting there's one
other type here we aren't checking for
that's the string I'm passing three two
yeah cuz that's like well we're gonna
have to again it's gonna be a pattern
thing right so yeah okay case string s
we're gonna have week sure
okay you know when my purse yes
it takes an out parameter so to do
something like this right what kind of
stinks about that is and so I could do
it down here
yeah so we're gonna add I and like I
haven't declared I so it until since is
fighting me oh that's misery oh hold on
and I'll finish this up here I'd have to
declare it outside this way go all the
way out there to declare the I that's
that is again it's offensive right I
keep saying that but I really feel
deeply offended by this one yeah
unfortunately there's a smudge to hello
it's much to the ROM this is called
space program
you know in a smudge based program SPD
yeah SPD SPD so I you know the last
release where we did c-sharp six we had
Visual Studio 27th 2015
I wrote an extension called c-sharp
essentials that had a whole bunch of
code fixes and analyzers for dealing
with new language features we just
jammed them all in the product right so
those are in here now and then we've
added more so this smudge in fact lets
you know that you can use the new out
fire feature
out bar out out variables right so I can
say in line this variable declaration
and it goes all the way down into there
and it puts a variable declaration right
in the out argument there yeah one of
the other thing is interesting in about
this is that before I'm gonna I'm gonna
go back and it might not been obvious
but this actually bumped up against one
of those rules in the c-sharp language
around switch that everybody kind of
hates but it's like a major breaking
change to do anything about so we're
never gonna but the the fact that right
right here this I conflicts with that
right so there's a squiggle by declaring
it in line here in the out bar that's
not a problem anymore so I can reuse
these variables in those cases yeah yeah
pretty cool so yeah and of course the
out bar the out parameter there you
could also actually if you don't care
about it but you didn't have to pass
something and you know the dummy that
you always have to declare and passing
as an out parameter you don't care about
you can use a discard again of course
there as well yeah it's just a pattern
right so they're all these places where
variables can now show up in expressions
yeah and in those places you can you can
often now declare the variable in place
like in this expression like here in the
in the out position we call those
expression variables and there you can
typically also use to discard yeah okay
well I think we're done with the c-sharp
77.1 II kind of stuff right now yeah
yeah you think I want to show a couple
more I do use things I've been trying to
sporadically you know assert myself over
Mads who tends to dominate these talks
and so five minutes all right now I'm
gonna be back with George so a couple of
things I'd like to point out we're doing
a lot of investment in the IDE
trying to make the c-sharp experience as
good as we can make it also just because
look we all know a lot of us are
installing products to kind of augment
the c-sharp experience right and there's
there's a lot of that that we feel kind
of embarrassed about like there are
features there that really should be in
the box and it kind of feels weird that
we you have to go get in our product so
we're making a lot of those in the box
and so there's a couple of features I
want to I want to demonstrate as we get
going here one of them is the the lines
that are connecting the braces that's
not an add-in that's not the
productivity to power tools it's
something that was in the proactivity
power tools but we brought it into the
product and connects those braces so you
can line that up visually right that's
new and Visual Studio 2017 something
everybody forgets to mention is that you
can hover over these things and it shows
you kind of the structure of what you're
what what those braces kind of use as
you would pop out to the to the blocks
outside of that what you're looking at
so if you're way off screen you know you
can you can look and say oh yeah that's
that switch that's set for each all the
way up that's pretty cool something else
we've also done in this release it's
time to try and put it kind of a new
skin on on existing features so like
final references back in I think 2015 we
shipped shipped it and it had like a big
flat list and then we at the last second
did a thing so we could at least group
things and kind of nest them and but
this big flat list of all references was
really hard to hard to visually kind of
separate and see what you're looking at
so we went grouping and then this
release we went a little nuts and we
made so that you could that it would
actually be colorized and and and show
it was just a much better presentation
so if you're on a large solution with
references all over the projects you see
where things come from you'll notice
that at the top there there's a group by
that you can actually change you know
how you want these to be visualized how
you want them to be grouped in the
update because we're a little silly but
it's actually an interesting feature we
added it so that you can do final
references on literals right so on
literal values so right here I'm on the
number one if I want to see where the
number one is used throughout I can I
can put final references on the notice
that finds the binary one two which is
kind of cool
but yeah is this just a nice little
feature it's in it's in up this new
update through this coming you want a
clap for that for finding the number one
so it's good I mean it's it's a thing
right so I mean so now we can we can
grep with shift f12 effectively I'm
gonna go and I'm good for those like
magic constants right yeah total that
find them in and in fact of the matter
of them let's see I've got I've got some
other demos I wanna show so I'm gonna
I'm gonna switch over so well first I
want to I'm gonna get rid of this junk
here so let's let's kill the stuff we've
been doing I'm gonna kind of kind of
roll back here one sec yeah isn't that
fun this is this is engineering that's
what you do oh that's because you guys
just totally rock that yeah so I'm gonna
I'm gonna check out branch I've got for
doing IDE demos also when I was looking
in here there was another branch I
wanted to use it was this one right here
yeah I do want to use that I'm gonna use
it too well first let me come back here
I want to see because I'm just kind of
getting myself first to a clean slate
and let's go ahead and merge that
awesome branch yeah okay awesome branch
I can't wait you know though there's a
con geyser merge conflict and that is
also what engineering is all about yeah
so there's a merge conflict now this is
a feature we haven't talked about much
but it's super useful and it was
championed in by one of the developers
on the team that really really loves
this feature and it's fantastic but the
idea here is that it actually required
us to do some some parser changes to be
able to kind of recognize these tokens
for these markers for that represent
merge conflicts right and so it gives us
squiggles on these they're actually
colored now as comments and so it's not
just like your codes not going
completely crazy and it tries to
continue you know limping along but also
we added a code fix to be able to say so
I want to take head don't want to take
awesome branch or do I want to take them
both I don't want to take them both I
kind of want to take off some branch
yeah I think you sure yeah okay so
that's a brand new feature that's in
2017 it's one yeah
that's really cool it's one of those
examples of being is one of those
examples of being right there in the
code doing more things right in the code
instead of having totally now I'm gonna
go ahead I want to show a feature but I
have to type a bunch so I'm typing a
super long string right now yeah that's
gonna go are all the way okay to the
right yeah wish you mad the regime's on
we can use the bigger front right now
because this is kind of taking a lot of
time well it's it's amazing I've typed
as well uncomfortable is a mild term for
what I am right now
as I like I don't know why it's forty
people are watching us yeah I guess I
guess I'm under pressure okay okay okay
okay so yes that was sufficiently long
again just a small little feature and
it's as we have this Roslyn
infrastructure and it's easier for us to
either take contributions if you feel
passionate about a feature go over to
the github ComNet Roslyn and and you
know submit a pull request or or
somebody just feels passion they just
want to go hammer something in overnight
and this is the one so I just come in
here and I press ENTER cuz I don't want
to see this like that I want to just
read the inter guys in catenation
[Applause]
and like I could be a developer now just
press Enter I'll give me one more give
me one more and then we move on to
c-sharp eight so yeah so I'm gonna
declare a type Here I am actually
because I'm a big geek and I'm not as
comfortable with normal money I spend it
immediately so but this is something I'm
super comfortable with right and so I
value to be able to do this RPG
it's a developer thing no no that's
that's a nerd thing I'll talk to me
afterwards I'll get you to turn your
nerd card back in in this form of money
we have platinum and so I'm gonna go
ahead now I declared a constructor for
this I'm adding a parameter and some of
those little nice little features that
you can tend to use other tools to do or
help to do or write snippets for again
we're putting them in the box so
pressing ctrl dot here will now allow me
to create and initialize a property for
that immediately and so I can go very
quick write filling this guy out
[Applause]
I can even I can even come up here now
and well this is a value type and if
anybody has created a proper value type
that actually you know handles equality
and all that it's kind of a pain so I'll
come up here and I'll use some helpers
for that generating equals and get hash
code allowing me to pick the members I
want I want them all and I come down
here and it's a little hash code
implementation it's what the heck is
this number
it was totally raised easy it looks
random yeah I'm gonna introduce a
constant for all occurrences because
that is that is silly that is magic but
it's also you know if I convert to
binary it doesn't look like it's
actually all that Ram oh wow look at
that that's kind of wasn't that random
after all it's got can you put some add
some separators in there oh yeah sure
separate the nibbles I feel that we
might make this past code review okay so
that's enough idea stuff yep let's talk
about what they're actually here for
they've been waiting like 55 minutes
yeah and now we have seven and a half
minute left to talk about next major
release of sea shark affectionately
known as sea char bait yeah we have a
few prototypes of features we are hoping
to put into seed and we want to show
them to you what do you want to do first
oh hold on I gotta get out of here this
is again this is its dev work I'm so
okay okay go ahead and dev while we're
doing a talk so I think we want to talk
about default interface implementations
what is he pulling up in a sec because I
just want to leading and the right to
the right feature that you're gonna show
so the thing here is so interfaces
sometimes you know this just sometimes
it's just the thing that everybody the
way that everybody implements an
interface method also more importantly
evolving interfaces is really hard right
you can't if you had a new member to an
interface you're breaking everyone was
already implementing it and so
essentially you're stuck with your
interfaces forever and not being able to
add new stuff right so we've got
something like this now this is this is
pretty simple right I've got an
interface that has a method M one I
implement it on a class and if I if I
run this you can see down here that I
I create a new instance of c1 and then I
call em 1 through the interface right
I've casted I've ensure that it's
implicitly converted to the interface
and that should work pretty well but you
know it's it's such a simple thing what
if I could do this yeah just implement
it on the interface right and so then I
can I can press f10 which will you know
build and start debugging and let me
step in it's kind of say that it's still
running in c1 but that's because your
interface is printing c1 out
oh yeah will it'll say that I can I can
fix that actually so I'm gonna step in
and it actually calls in the interface
I'll go ahead and I think I can edit and
continue your gonna edit and continue in
this prototype in a prototype I am crazy
and so sure did yeah okay that works
yeah I know lund they're not all that
impressed the idea is so no no I think
the big value prop here is so that
couple of value props the general value
proposition here is that you can now add
new members to interfaces as long as you
give them a default implementation
because then all the existing
implementers they can just use that
default implementation they don't break
right well as long as that does
something sensible for everyone here's a
good example right so I've got a logging
interface here right this is the sort of
thing where you're like okay this is an
interface that if I wanted to add a
member to this and I I wanted to I
wanted to I wanted some of them now I
wanted to be able to implement that
member that would be a breaking change
to all the potential loggers out there
right so I've got a console logger I get
to lemon tree logger but what if I
wanted to add one that took an exception
right well I could do that I could add
it here this would be a breaking change
for everybody right now they would all
have to go implement that okay and you
say well you could do this with an
extension method sure the red squiggles
right away oh the red squiggles there
yes you actually see it showing up yeah
but if I go and add a body for it and I
can do this by calling the log that I
have here already and we can just pass
to string and give it kind of a default
implementation we're good now again
something I can do with extension
methods today but the thing I can't do
with extension methods is to have
specialization on one or more of the
implementers if they want to its this
becomes something that's a little bit
more optional go ahead and implement
this without having to do something like
add an eye log or two interface or
something if that's oh I could come down
here and say void log error or it's just
log right that's what I call it yeah
with an exception and now this is the
one that will get called if the instance
happens to be this and so this is where
it becomes much more interesting than
doing an extension method because then I
might want to say well you know capture
crash dump and send message because it's
my telemetry logger for example so this
is the main value prop or a big value
problem not the main one but yeah so
well you go well you go queue up the
nullable thing yeah one thing to note is
other languages already have this
feature Java has it Swift acid and
funnily enough those two languages are
the the languages in which the the API
is on on Android and iOS are exposed and
so we like to wrap those force a marine
and and right now we can't faithfully
wrap api's that have that make use of
this feature that have default
implementations in their interfaces and
so this is very concretely this is going
to go and solve that problem make it
much nicer to wrap API is direction from
other languages originally and have a
smooth nice interface on the c-sharp
side or in the dotnet side for salmon
okay the last one this is actually I
haven't yet shortcuts on my desktop I
have one says medium-hot vs bits this is
super hot vs bits okay lazing hot
blazing how they could not change the
icon to have the little flag that's so
sorry about that but the idea here is
I've got a database that I'm loading
some text from right I just want to
count lines with you know in that text
with the character X okay and I'm sorry
with it sorry
use the correct variable name solves all
problems but it doesn't actually saw the
problem there's actually a warning right
there and that warning says there might
be a possible null reference of argument
for the parameter text what was that
about well what's happening here is
we've we've my load text method I said
hey the thing that comes back here it's
possible that this could be null
if I hover over it you'll see in fact
that it's defined as string question
mark okay meaning I can annotate and say
this is something that could possibly be
null and so now I have a possible null
reference because this also does not say
it can be null so I can come down here
and I can declare this reference type
it's nullable saying now I accept null
here yes make sure you have a choice
yeah I help you deal with your null
reference exception to compile it I
could also do this choose to you can
choose to either check for null first
and the compiler will say all right we
know it's not null you're free to pass
actually run way go you're doing it
there right yeah that way actually so
there's a flow analysis here saying he
checked that that thing was not know if
we will allow it to be passed does not
know yeah instead of introducing some
new way of checking for all in the
language we just recognize the ones
you're using now down here now I'm gonna
get a null dereference right here saying
this is possibly null so we could come
in and say well if text equals null then
we'll do that special case that just
returns zero because we know that
haven't found any so this is a way that
we can we can help you as you're writing
code to not write so many of those darn
bugs yeah so the core of that feature is
giving you syntax to express your intent
is this thing supposed to be null well
in that case protected against being
dereferenced until somebody checked that
it isn't alright is it not supposed to
be no well in that case protect you from
putting null in it or from leaving all
in it as the default value or in a field
or whatever yeah so so that's the idea
of the feature
give your annotations in your that you
can put your code give you warnings when
you don't act according to those
annotations yeah and that's so we call
inaudible reference types not non null
reference types yeah well it's sort of
the rest of the reference types then you
can sort of think of as none knowable
okay I had a triple negative there not
none no no okay yeah yeah okay
we're down to the wire yeah can you flip
back to your slides quickly who's worse
I'm officially off if you're on the live
stream bye-bye so I just want to mention
very like super super quickly the
another few features we're thinking
about for
for c-sharp 8 so this the next step of a
sync which is essentially dealing with
streams of events or data that are is
essentially asynchronous allowing you to
reach over those and have like you are a
weight nice code like you have with a
with a weight on single values today
also sometimes your disposal needs to be
a sync well maybe we have an Isaac
disposable that using recognizes and and
will await the disposed finish we have
extension methods in Satish f3 oh maybe
we have some way of doing extension
other things including properties all
kinds of static members operators maybe
constructors can we generalize to
extension everything that'd be really
cool and it's very frequently asked also
Dustin had a type before that was very
value based and all the defaults of
c-sharp in essence are wrong for when
you have want to have immutable value
like types well what if there was a
syntax where you could just have that be
the default like records in other
languages and that would just generate
all that equals and get hash code and
deconstructors and constructors and
whatnot from that very simple thing you
wrote up there so those are some things
that we are thinking about as we're
going forward here's some resources you
can take a quick picture and and go for
instance engage with that language
design process and get up if you want to
and and and throw in your two cents
yeah just one word I also want to
mention that what we put up there is
c-sharp eight that article you're about
to go write that says all that's in
c-sharp eight yeah might be wrong it
might be totally wrong yeah so just see
where as this intention yeah we the
intention is these are the things we're
talking about I'm working on right now
that would go into a bigger room now our
intention is to wrap up here yes and and
if you want to talk more we're gonna
head down to the booth the C share
visual and visual basic and F sharp ooh
that's hitting somewhere in the corner
in the expo
if you don't catch us there we're on
twitter so is Rosslyn and so thank you
very much for coming thanks for sitting
nicely
thing
[Applause]